vous nous avez demandé s'il fallait
retirer le germe des gousses d'ail pour
en faciliter la digestion et diminue et
l'amertume il faut savoir que ce germe
verdâtre contient plus d'envié mais deux
composés à base de soufre que le reste
de la goutte lorsque la et couper ces
composés produisent de l'allicine une
molécule très odorante au goût amer
responsable de la saveurs typiques de
l'aïe le magazine américain cox et le
street aide à comparer à l'aveuglent d
ayo nier départ talayan huile d'olive
préparé avec de l'ail entier ou déjà
remis les dégustateurs ont affirmé que
les versions préparé avec de l'ail
entier avait un goût âpre et amer plus
prononcé 1 ce qui concerne la digestion
la présence du germe ne change rien au
processus ce serait plutôt l'hérault qui
serait plus à doha